it's time now for CBS morning's deals
and today we're sharing three items that
might help make your day a little bit
better all of course and exclusive
discounts to start shopping now go get
your phone scan the QR code on your
screen or visit cbsdeals.com they always
forget the phone they always go running
for the phone it happens and you
shouldn't because we've got great deals
today yes we do Gail basket to see you
again good to see you again and you know
what people want to go to cbsdeals.com
because we brought back some favorites
that people really need to get on right
now and we're going to start with a
calming heat Network crap I want you to
stand right there and be relaxed not at
the White House anymore no you are not
at the White House here we go what do we
got that anything in your pockets okay
right there you feel the vibration you
feel the heat think about it when people
have a sore neck from bending their neck
over on their computers and you know all
the next stream we get you go to the
store and you get a heating pad a
heating pad is not portable and it
doesn't I mean it might be portable but
it doesn't wrap around your neck like
you want it to this is designed
specifically for your neck it's warming
it's vibrating and it's got nice fabric
it's velvet and for people with bigger
necks there's an extent for it I said
for people with bigger Nets that fits
you just fine nobody said you had a big
deck but we have a big discount
40 off so we've got it for
23.99 but you can wrap your neck in love
Yeah heat vibration and it's got It's
got clay in there so yeah so that's the
vibration it's trying to be employee of
the months you're working you're go buy
it now right now QR code right there see
where is it right
it turns off after two hours I read the
material it turns off after two hours if
you fall asleep wearing this it turns
off after two hours it's not relaxing
yes I know because I've fallen asleep
did my homework all right now I'm gonna
revolutionize laundry okay because smell
this smells wonderful this is from clean
I got all sorts of sensory this is
laundry detergent that is this is
laundry detergent um this is 96 loads of
laundry in this box think about this
this is heavy think about carrying that
up the stairs to the laundry or down to
the laundry this is great from clean
people because this is eco-friendly it's
it's vegan made it's basic it's
plant-based all right it is plant-based
how much is it this we have 23 23.99 and
I have video on how easy it is to use
because for smaller loads you split it
in half which what I did split it in
half throw it in there you throw it in
there first then you throw in your you
got a minute to play some games this is
the most popular growing sport in
America if I break anything
oh all right all right y that battery
fell oh my god did you see the spin on
that yeah this is for moroccany very
much all right and these are the
pickleball paddles you want to have if
you haven't played yet if you do play
from beginners to professionals you want
to use the Rockne pickleball paddle and
they have a great sale it's amazing how
quickly you can pick up the sport you
can pick it up quickly ate it twice yes
it's great it's that's why it's the
fastest growing sport people from all
backgrounds and all ages are playing as
we also playing thank you Gail of course
we partner with all these companies to
get these Oh by anything excited
including this incredible neck rub scan
that QR code or head to cbsdeals.com
start shopping now